un estadístico de un equipo de
baloncesto llevó al registro del número
de puntos que cada uno de los 12
jugadores del equipo ha obtenido en un
juego después realizó un diagrama de
tallos y hojas para mostrar los datos
cuántos puntos hizo el equipo en total y
bueno en una primera instancia uno ve
este diagrama y dice que representa este
diagrama tenemos por una parte los
tallos 012 y por otra parte tenemos las
hojas y tenemos un buen de dígitos y
bueno la manera de interpretar esta
información es que en primer lugar las
hojas contienen el menor dígito o el
primer dígito en el número de puntos que
hizo o que anotó cada jugador mientras
que los tallos en segundo lugar
representan las decenas en general vamos
a hablar en general las hojas siempre
van a representar las unidades de lo que
sea mientras que los tallos van a
representar los demás dígitos
por ejemplo en este caso podemos ver que
la mayoría de los jugadores tienen como
decena de la cantidad de puntos que
anotaron cero
otros pocos tienen como decena de la
cantidad que anotaron uno y solamente
uno fue aquel que hizo la cantidad de
puntos que empieza con las decenas dos y
de hecho si se dan cuenta hizo 20 puntos
pero bueno primero vamos a analizar qué
pasa con los tallos que empiezan con
cero es decir tenemos siete personas
cuyos tallos empiezan con cero es decir
que tienen cero decenas en la cantidad
de puntos que hicieron vamos a ponerlo
así para que se note con mayor claridad
los siete números de los puntos que
hicieron estos siete jugadores el primer
jugador hizo cero decenas y cero
unidades el segundo también cero decenas
con cero unidades es decir estos dos
jugadores no notaron nada en todo el
partido el tercero metió a los primeros
dos puntos es decir cero escenas con dos
unidades el cuarto metió cero decenas
con cuatro unidades el quinto metió cero
decenas con siete unidades recuerden que
cero decenas porque tenemos en nuestro
tallo cero y el sexto hizo también cero
decenas con siete unidades recuerden que
es siete porque es el número que tenemos
en nuestra hoja
y por último el séptimo jugador tiene
cero escenas con nueve unidades y ya
tenemos por fin la cantidad de puntos
que hicieron los primeros siete
jugadores aquellos jugadores cuyo tallo
era cero dense cuenta que vamos por muy
buen camino para resolver la pregunta
porque menos ya tenemos las nueve
cantidades de puntos que hicieron los
primeros siete jugadores y si queremos
la cantidad de puntos total que hicieron
en todo el juego pues vamos a sumar cada
una de las cantidades bueno ahora vamos
a fijarnos qué pasa cuando tenemos el
tallo 1 por lo tanto son 4 jugadores y
voy a poner 1 1 1 1 el primero de esos
cuatro jugadores hizo uno en las decenas
y uno en las unidades por lo tanto hizo
once puntos el segundo también hizo uno
en las escenas y uno en las unidades por
lo tanto también hizo once puntos este
de aquí hizo también once puntos bien
qué pasa con el tercero del tallo número
uno pues hizo uno en decenas y tres en
unidades es decir trece puntos y el
cuarto de ellos hizo uno en decenas y
ocho en unidades es decir hizo 18 puntos
hasta
ha sido el jugador que más puntos ha
metido entonces uno en decenas ocho
unidades y son 18 puntos muy bien hasta
ahorita tenemos la cantidad de puntos
que hicieron los primeros 11 jugadores
nos falta el último jugador que tiene el
tallo número 2 y siguiendo esta misma
lógica pues tiene 2 decenas y en la
cantidad de unidades van a ser 0 por lo
tanto va a tener dos decenas ser
unidades este jugador metió 20 puntos
fue el jugador que más puntos metió y
bueno fíjense y dense cuenta de que este
diagrama de hojas y tallos tiene una
distribución muy especial pues lo que
hace es juntar todos los datos del 0 al
9 después del 10 al 19 y por último
todos los datos del 20 al 29
es decir clasifica todos los datos según
la cantidad de puntos que tengan pero
bueno ya tenemos todos los puntos que
hizo cada uno de los jugadores en el
partido entonces la pregunta era cuántos
puntos hicieron en total todo el equipo
durante el partido entonces vamos a
sumar cada uno de estos puntos primero
voy a ir de más grande al más chico 20
más 18
13 11 más otros 11 más nueve puntos más
siete puntos dos veces o sea más 77
después tenemos un cuatro y por último
tenemos un dos porque recuerden que los
dos primeros jugadores no hicieron nada
de puntos y ahora sí si sumamos la
cantidad de puntos que hizo cada jugador
durante todo el partido vamos a
encontrar la cantidad de puntos que hizo
todo el equipo durante todo el partido
por lo tanto vamos a sumar 83 son once
más uno son doce más uno son trece las
nueve son 22 más siete son 27 más 7 son
34 más 4 son 38 más dos son 40 si 40
entonces le pongo un cero aquí y
llevamos 4 vamos a rectificar 83 son
once más uno son doce más uno son trece
más nueve son 22 más siete son 29 más
siete son 36 más cuatro son cuarenta más
dos son 42 42 o no creo que estoy
confundido no no no mejor empecemos otra
vez desde el inicio otra vez voy a
borrar todo
y vamos a rectificar 8 y 3 son 11 y 2
son 13 y 9 son 22 y 7 son 29 y 7 son 29
20 30 y 36 40 y 26 y en efecto son 42
llevamos 4 y entonces 4 y 200 6 7 8 9 10
102 puntos por lo tanto el equipo en
total hizo 102 puntos durante todo el
partido